sechs kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video danke
im letzten video der whatsapp video zwar
genau so wie es mir vorgestellt hab echt
mega cool daumen nach oben dafür lassen
zeigt dabei heute machen es ein bisschen
anders wer in mir ist was sehr sehr sehr
krasses passiert was ich euch heute in
dem video erzählen möchte dafür habe ich
euch heute einen gameplay aufgenommen
was jetzt im hintergrund zwar ist das
aber das match war also bleibt bei
windmann haben bis zum ende ich jetzt
hoch in die ecke als page kennen und die
geschichte geht los das ganze ist am
dienstag passiert freut euch das
aufnehme ist mittwoch der zwölfte
gestern dienstag am 11.10 ist passiert
mit mir man sonst ja das ganze ist
gestern passiert wie gesagt ich hab'
dienstags von 10 bis 19 juni und eine
mittagspause von 12 30 bis 13 30 so
diese mittagspause wollte ich nutzen um
ein bisschen nach hause zu fahren wir
medikamente zu holen weil ich gestern
ein bisschen kälter war als heute ja und
dann ist es passiert ich habe keinen
bock allein nach hause zu fahren also
meinem auto allein nach hause zu fahren
deswegen ja startet also mit zwei
kumpels ab heute klingt jetzt komisch
aber ich hab keinen bock allein nach
hause zu fahren will lieber mit fahren
meint einer ja klar ich komme mit kein
ding
beide stiegen dann sind losgefahren und
wir sind nicht weit gekommen ja wir sind
einmal so geradeaus 300 meter dann um
die ecke und dann ist es passiert
ich will es einfach den modus ist nach
hause fahren sie mit meinem kollegen
geplauscht weiter geradeaus auf einmal
rechts ist eine einfach zu irgendwo fair
und die hat natürlich obwohl sie von
rechts kommt nicht vorfahrt es ist nicht
das ich rechts vor links also ich bin so
gefahren ich bin so gefahren und hier
rechts geht so eine auffahrt von ihrem
hof runter aber es ist eine aufnahme von
einem hoch und die konnten geht über den
bordstein die auffahrt das heißt hier
ist nicht rechts vor links als rechts
hat vorfahrt
sondern die straße ja vorfall weil die
seit über den bordstein kommt und quasi
eine untergeordnete straße ist also die
ganze geschichte die wir so ich fahre so
geradeaus auf die kreuzung zu ferrari
vor ex komplett verwalter verwalter
ganze mal dass der bub war nicht zu
schnell
das war das tempo merkel noch einmal so
ok
die fährt bis sich schnell auf die
kreuzung zu die fed bisschen sehr
schneller auf die kreuz hinzu ich ziehe
nach links rüber
die zieht auch nach links rüber oder
bars knall die mir volle kanne ins auto
ob volle kanne mich so sehr wie man bei
der geschwindigkeit mit volle kanne ein
knallen kann also die ist wirklich so
schnell aus dieser ausfahrt raus
gefahren das war nicht wie man
normalerweise das macht so dass man ein
bisschen rostocker dem ersten gang an
die kreuzung sollen dies wirklich mit 20
sachen würde ich sagen aus dieser
ausfahrt raus obwohl sie links abgebogen
ist das müsst ihr euch vergeben
man fährt aus der ausfahrt auch eine
große straße hat sowieso nicht vorfahrt
und muss auch noch links abbiegen
das heißt also schon mal doppelt
langsamer geschwindigkeit und fährt dann
so rein und ja sie habe ich aber nicht
gesehen weil er irgendwann schild
dazwischen war das war ihre version der
geschichte
kann sein auf jeden fall hat die mich
richtig hart getroffen und hier ist ein
bild von dem schaden
also das war nicht nur ein streifschaden
soll der reifen des geplatz felge
verbogen ultra viele blechteile
eingedellt
das auto ist eventuell total schreiben
was richtig richtig krass ist also
totalschaden heiß für die es nicht
wissen dass die reparatur des autos mehr
kosten würde als das auto jetzt wert ist
das heißt das auto ist schrott das auto
was die letzten drei jahre gefahren bin
ist jetzt wahrscheinlich short das auch
schon mal heftig zu verdauen und das
kraft war leute in dem moment saß ein
kumpel von mir wenn luca heißt der auf
der auf dem beifahrersitz okay wir
stellen ich jetzt noch mal nach ich war
so und wie gesagt die kommt von der
seite und tag erwische ich wäre ich in
dem moment an links ausgewichen und sie
nicht auch nach links ausgewichen hätten
wir uns so erwischt und die hätte
einfach mein beifahrer so cent deppert
so wieder in die kreuzung eingefahren
ist all das ist wirklich wirklich
wirklich gefährlich leute habt im
straßenverkehr wirklich immer ich würde
ich auch sagen fahrt immer mit helm
fahrrad wenn ihr fahrrad fahre ich weiß
es nicht so cool aber nutzt eure eigenen
sicherheit weit wäre ich jetzt auf dem
fahrrad gewesen diese situation die alte
mich so um gebügelt die hat mich platt
gemacht ja kein großes auto oder so aber
das reicht 20 sachen rein buhrufen
fahrrad bahn
und dann hast du wenn du kein helm auf
fast und pech hast hast du was ich was
einen schädelbasisbruch oder was richtig
heftig ist also da muss man wirklich
vorsichtig seine solchen situation ist
kann ja es kann immer knallt es ging
wirklich mal knallen ist krass wird
silvester dann sind wir da ausgestiegen
nach dem unfall bei der raus aus den
autos total geschockt zueinander
ich habe dir erstmal bisschen angebracht
ein kleines bisschen also ich bin immer
arbeiten bin ich der typ die leute
runter macht aber da sondern spinnst du
weißt schon dass er nicht vorsitzender
und die kanal wie die reagiert hat
irgendwie gar nicht die waren nicht
mitgenommen kanal voll komisch
eigentlich man das war eine heftige
situation in dem moment wo ich ihn
getroffen hat war es eigentlich wie
autoscooter zwischen dem autoscooter auf
dem jahrmarkt gefahren ich war einfach
geradeaus sehe sie kommt von der seite
und ich weiß okay scheiße da kommen wir
nicht mehr außen rum
es gibt gleich einen knall also die sich
noch weit darüber und dann ist es im
autoscooter wenn ihr seht dass seine
absicht zukommt macht zieht den kopf
zwischen die schultern dreht sich
bisschen weg von der seite wo der
treffer kommt und dann hat der verband
gemacht und ja bereits im blatt auto
totalschaden
super tag super tag wo leute das war
nicht das erste mal dass was passiert
ist ich fahre das auto jetzt zwei jahre
oder so neben diesen zwei jahren das mit
zwei mal recht die rechte heftiger
ordentlich heftiger unfall passiert und
zwar einmal habe ich auch wieder drüber
gemacht hat das will ich euch hier gerne
verlinken wahrscheinlich machen irgendwo
da da bin ich auf der autobahn 8
gefahren meine mutter war am chiemsee am
chiemsee unten in bayern war die in der
reha aber die nokia hatte besuchte
bayern münchen vorbei und irgendwann vor
münchen nachts um 1 uhr nachts um zwei
ist ein typ neben mir dachte sich heißt
was ich will einfach ein bisschen
schlafen ja ich bin müde es 81 am steuer
am steuer penn oder willst du denn ich
weiß nicht was mit ihr passiert ist
damals ist auch am meer
ich war gerade aus 230 so kommt der
wobei überholt mich und dachte sich im
moment entweder so ich hab jetzt ein
oder
[ __ ] you weil er einfach so damit bei
130 ist er wirklich so wie meine seite
rein und das war der erste schaden das
war glaube ich letztlich ein juli oder
august es ist wirklich nicht lange her
maximal wirklich maximalen jahr
dazwischen zwei mal zwei richtig heftige
unfälle wie das auto einfach gekippt
heißt ich muss mir ich muss mir und das
fällt gar nicht so schlecht ich muss
mein neues auto zulegen
vielleicht habt ihr irgendwelche ideen
für ein neues auto also was sinnvolles
jahr schreibt jetzt nicht lambo r8 oder
sowas in die kommentare wenn ich ein see
der lambracht einschreiben wenn ihr
selbst wenn irgendwelche ideen ab
irgendwelche autos die ihr cool findet
wohl sagen würde das mal anders ein
gutes auto ist solide
das ist vor einigen für langstrecken gut
weil ich lange strecken fahren kann
jetzt mal die kommentare schreiben
momentan dachte ich da also golf oder
seat leon
den finde ich richtig cool wenn ihr euch
gedanken die richtung ab könnte es gerne
unten rein schreiben und ja ich
verabschiede mich heute mit so einem
video was ich so auch noch nie gemacht
habe